J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE:
OK, so we're going to finish
up on nucleophilic substitution
elimination
reactions today with an example
of practical
application of them.
And then go on to the reverse
reaction of elimination, which
is addition to alkenes, so a new
functional group.
And we'll be talking about the
stability of them today, the
stability alkenes.
OK, so last time we got started
on the silver assisted
substitution reaction of
neopentyl iodide.
And notice something interesting
in this, if we
look at those red crosses that
trace the carbon skeleton of
the starting material and the
product, what do you notice
about the carbon skeleton?
Does it look like a normal
substitution?
Ellen, what do you say?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Why?
STUDENT: There's an extra
carbon.
PROFESSOR: There's not an extra
There's five carbons on the
left, and there are five
carbons on the right, but
they're not hooked together
the same way.
So there's been a rearrangement
of the carbon
skeleton during this reaction.
So how did this happen?
Well, silver comes down and
pulls off iodide, which would
generate this cation.
But in a cation we have a low
LUMO, obviously, on the
cationic carbon.
But there are HOMOs next door.
They're not very high HOMOs.
They're the C-C sigma bonds.
But you could imagine that since
primary cations are
rather unstable, and we'll give
some more evidence on
this later on, that you could
get a rearrangement, in which
first, the HOMO next door is
shared with the LUMO of the
carbon cation.
Did you ever see a structure
like that before, where the
pair of electrons is shared with
an adjacent atom?
That's the Y-bond, right?
The three-center two-electron
electron bond.
And then it could keep going,
which would give the tertiary
cation, a carbon cation with
three other carbons attached
to it, which is much more stable
than the
primary cation is.
In fact, it's possible that it
doesn't even go that way.
That at the same time the iodide
is leaving and
beginning to develop this
unstable primary cation, the
methyl next door should shift
across, so that you directly
get the cationic rearrangement
product.
But at any rate, once you have
the carbons rearranged like
that, it's a simple matter to
have--
and notice what that means is,
that the sigma of the
carbon-carbon sigma bond is
actually acting as a
nucleophile a displacement
reaction.
The carbon next door is backside
attack as the iodide
is leaving, but it's within the
molecule that the reaction
is occurring.
But then you can bring water
down of course, and finally
lose a proton, which will give
the product.
But the crucial thing is this
rearrangement, because the
fact of the rearrangement shows
that there must have
been a cation intermediate.
Without that cation, there would
have been no means for
the rearrangement to take place
in the carbon skeleton.
Carbons skeletons don't normally
rearrange.
But when you lose electrons and
can get these two-electron
three-center bonds, then a
carbon could move from one
place to the adjacent one.
So the fact of the rearrangement
shows that this
was an SN1 reaction, that there
was a cation
intermediate.
Had there been no cation
intermediate there couldn't
have been a rearrangement.
OK, let's think just a second
about the arrangements--
so-- we have at about this
three-center
two-electron bond.
So we could imagine bringing a
proton down, mixing with the
pi electrons to form a
three-center
two-electron bond.
We could also imagine bringing a
hydrogen down on one end of
an alkene to form a normal kind
of cation.
And of course it could go on the
other end too.
You can get from one of these to
the next by shifting the
hydrogen from left to right.
That's the rearrangement.
But the question is, is it a
single minimum, or is it a
double minimum?
Do you have two normal cations
which have a transition state
they can go across back and
forth between them that's not
too high, because it has this
three-center
two-electron bond?
Or might it be that that bridged
structure is in fact
the lowest energy structure, and
it's a single minimum?
So you can do simple
calculations to check this,
and you may or may not believe
them.
But these particular ones are
well supported by experimental
evidence that we don't have time
to go into right now.
But if you take the open
compound, that's what its HOMO
looks like.
And you notice that the HOMO,
which you would have guessed
from the structure on the top is
the sigma CH bond, in fact
is mixed with some of the
electron density in that HOMO,
or HOMO minus one it is, is
shared over onto
the cationic carbon.
It's distorted, you can see that
the electrons are
shifting that way.
And the LUMO is the other way
around, that there's something
vacancy of the orbitals that are
involved in the CH bond.
So you could imagine that
resonance structure, the one
that's drawn in color just below
to the right, but you
could also have this structure,
which is a proton
plus a carbon-carbon double
bond, or you could have a
resonance structure that has a
long stretched bond.
Remember when you draw resonance
structures, you
don't move the nuclei.
So you don't draw that hydrogen
over on the right,
you draw it with a really long
bond, because they have to be
at the same position.
And if you take those three
simultaneously into account,
it says you can have positive
charge either on the right
carbon, on the hydrogen, or on
the left carbon.
So that's what's denoted by
drawing this Y, that the two
electrons are shared among these
three centers, and the
positive charge, therefore, is
shared.
And we can see it in the
orbitals that
that's the way it works.
And of course it makes sense
that you should have that.
Of course, the CH sigma bond
isn't a very high HOMO, so
it's not drastically shifted,
not 50/50.
And we call that, the
stabilization due to that HOMO
LUMO mixing, hyperconjugation, I
think we've talked about
that before.
And incidentally, that's one of
the factors that makes
highly substituted carbon
cations stable.
Because if you have a hydrogen
next door, there's no way that
the electrons involved in that
bond can mix with the p
orbital, the vacant p orbital,
because they're orthogonal.
But if you have a carbon and
then a bond, the electrons in
that bond can overlap.
So the more carbons you have
attached to this carbon, the
more bonds there are whose
electrons could be stabilized
by mixing with the vacant
orbital.
So that hyperconjugation is one
reason that more
substituted cations are more
stable.
Now if we go to the bridged
structure, which is actually
symmetrically bridged, although
the program drew that
for its own reasons with a
different kind of bond, and if
we look at the HOMO, you can see
that it's symmetrical.
You can see it's the pi orbital,
but it's distorted
because the hydrogen orbital is
mixed with it.
And the LUMO is the antibonding
combination, or
the LUMO plus one in this case.
So you can see how those
orbitals participate.
But in fact, in this
calculation,
it's a double minimum.
The open structure is lower in
energy than the bridge
structure, so it's a double
minimum.
But it's different, instead of a
hydrogen on the top, you
have a methyl group on top.
Because the methyl has a
somewhat bigger orbital than
hydrogen does, so it's better at
overlapping two neighbors
than hydrogen was.
So now it turns out to be a
single minimum, that's the
lowest energy structure.
And again, you can see the HOMO,
which is a p orbital on
the carbon overlapping with pi,
and the LUMO, which I put
in only because I've been
drawing these things, but I
wouldn't spend a lot of time
worrying about that one.
But at any rate it's a single
minimum, so that structure is
in fact bridged.
Now here I've made the alkene,
the C-C double bond,
unsymmetrical, such that a
carbon cation would be more
stable on one side than on the
other, one side is more
substituted.
And in this case, it distorts so
that it's sort of a double
minimum, but the one side is
very low, so it's an
unsymmetrical cation, and open,
not strongly bridged.
That's its structure, and
there's the HOMO, which again
is somewhat mixed, but don't
waste time
looking at those things.
I just put them in because I had
them.
But anyhow, it's a sort of
double minimum in the sense
that it's not a bridged
structure, but it's
unsymmetrical and open.
OK now, SN1 and E1, there's an
interesting thing about the
stereochemistry of SN1
reactions.
If you substitute the chloride
here, this tertiary chloride,
you could imagine getting either
the OH group
substituted directly where the
chloride was, or the OH group
on the opposite face of the
chloride.
Now what would you expect if it
was SN1?
What about if the SN1--
so the rate determining step is
ionization, you get a
cation intermediate, what
structure do you expect for a
carbon cation?
We talked about this last
semester in XH3.
So it's the same number of
electrons as BH3.
There's no electrons in that
fourth orbital.
What should that orbital be?
There are four atomic orbitals
on the carbon, or boron in
BH3, but you only have electrons
in three of them.
How should you hybridize it?
sp2 to get the strongest bonds,
and leave the vacancy
in the highest energy orbital,
the p orbital, so
it should be planar.
Now if you get a planar
intermediate, how much attack
should be from one side versus
how much on the other?
Should be 50/50.
But in fact, when you do the
experiment as it says here,
you get 40% retention, and 60%
inversion.
So 80% of it is racemization,
that's what you expect, that
is 40% of right, 40% of left
handed.
But the other 20% is excess
inversion.
It should have been 100% if
there was a planar
intermediate cation.
Can anybody see how you might
explain this?
How could it be that you indeed
form a cation, but it's
not equally attacked from the
two faces?
Mostly it's attacked from the
face opposite the chloride
ion, where the chloride ion came
from.
Why should it be mostly opposite
where the
chloride came from?
STUDENT: Steric-steric
hinderance
PROFESSOR: Can't hear very well.
STUDENT: Steric-steric
hindrance?
PROFESSOR: Steric hindrance of
what?
STUDENT: The electrons in the
chlorine atom.
PROFESSOR: Right, the chloride,
even
though it's broken the bond, for
a certain time is still
around blocking access to the
side it came from.
So the idea to explain the net
inversion is that that
chloride, for a short time, is
still there, even though it's
not bonded.
So it temporarily blocks the
face that would lead to
retention to give the same
stereochemistry coming in
where the chloride was, and you
get more of the water
coming in from the opposite
face.
So this short lived ion pair
gives an explanation for the
net inversion.
So even though people would
usually say that SN1 gives
racemization, in truth it
doesn't always do so, although
it depends on the solvent.
Because the more the solvent can
stabilize ions, the faster
it can get the ions apart from
one another, the less of this
affect you would have. So it
depends on the polarity of the
solvent, that was acetone and
water.
We talked about this elimination
reaction, the
t-butyl bromide with sodium
hydroxide gives a large amount
of the alkene.
But is that process that gives
the alkene E1 or E2?
That is, is the rate determining
step formation of
the t-butyl cation, and then the
hydroxide attacks it?
Or is the rate determining step
attack of the hydroxide
on a hydrogen, pulling it off at
the same time that the
chloride leaves?
So how could you tell?
How could you tell whether it's
E1 or E2?
Luke?
STUDENT: Maybe test the rate?
PROFESSOR: What about the rate?
STUDENT: See if it's
bimolecular.
PROFESSOR: See if that's
what the names mean.
So you could follow the names.
E2 means it's bimolecular, that
the rate depends on the
concentration of hydroxide.
If the rate limiting step were
breaking the bond, no
hydroxide involved there, so the
rate
wouldn't depend on that.
So you can look at the overall
rate, not just the percent of
alkene, because more hydroxide
could mean that, even though
in the rate determining step you
made the cation, the more
hydroxide, the more hydrogens
you pull off, compared to
water attacking.
So if you see the rate, not just
the product ratio, but
the rate depends on hydroxide,
then it's E2.
OK, another way to see whether
the proton is being pulled
away in the rate limiting step,
is to look for a kinetic
isotope effect.
Remember that hydrogen is faster
than deuterium by a
factor of up to about six or
seven usually, only when
you're breaking the bond in the
transition state.
If the transition state is
forming the ions, and later
you break the proton away, then
you wouldn't see a
hydrogen being faster than
deuterium.
OK, now this was a question I
asked on an exam once.
Give an example of the influence
of a change in
reactant structure on the ratio
of SN2 to E2 products.
Be as specific and quantitative
as you can.
And the simplest minded answer
to such a thing, it would be
neat to have a more subtle
example, but a really simple
one is methyl bromide.
How about the amount of SN2 and
E2 in that case?
Anybody venture a guess?
This is in fact a trick
question.
Wojciech.
I can't hear.
STUDENT: There cannot be an
elimination.
PROFESSOR: There are not two
carbons, you
can't make an alkene, there's no
hydrogen on the adjacent
carbon, so obviously that's
going to be all SN2.
So that was sort of a trick.
But then in this one, we've seen
from last time that it's
much easier to do with a high
concentration of hydroxide,
it's much easier to do SN2 than
E2, to the extent--
pardon me, to do E2 than SN2,
because
the SN2 is so hindered.
If you get substitution, it's
SN1 in the cases we saw last
time and looking at the rates of
the various RBr's.
Now these are really drastic
ratios.
Now there are two different
organic chemical perspectives
on situations where you have
drastic ratios.
One is the perspective of a
synthetic organic chemist, who
says it's great to have drastic
ratios, because then
you have a reliable way to get a
really high yield.
It's not going to be 40/60 or
something like that, and you
have to separate and throw away
the stuff you don't want.
You get all the stuff you want,
that's great.
But for a physical organic
chemist trying to understand
mechanism, if you have a really
drastic ratio, then the
energy of activation is quite
different between the two, and
you can often get an unambiguous
interpretation of
what the cause of what's
determining the rate if you
can get a really big difference.
If you have just a small
difference, you can't be so
confident that it's not just
some subtle change in
solvation or something.
So for example, the 10^3 steric
retardation of
isopropyl via SN2, remember you
had substitution at
methyl, at ethyl, at isopropyl,
they
got slower and slower.
Isopropyl was 1,000 times slower
than methyl.
So that's a pretty big effect,
1,000 times, 10 to the third.
That meant it must be 4
kilocalories per mole at room
temperature difference in those
two.
So that's pretty big, that's not
like half a kilocalorie or
something like that.
So a factor of 1,000 or more
often you can be confident in
interpreting.
Or in the case of t-butyl,
remember it jumped way back up
again, it was accelerated by
10^5 compared to isopropyl, by
putting that next one in, which
showed that there was a
new mechanism coming in, the
formation of the cation
intermediate.
Now what if the ratio is not
drastic?
What if the two products that
you could get form in about a
50/50 ratio?
The synthetic organic chemist
says this is deadly, because
he's doing a lot of reactions in
a row to
try to get some product.
If each reaction has a 50%
yield, and you do a whole
bunch of them in sequence, for
example if you did 12 steps
getting a 50% yield at each
step, you'd have a yield at
the end of one half to the 12th
power, 0.02%.
So a synthetic chemist wants a
reaction that gives a really,
really high yield.
Although it might be possible to
have a reaction that
doesn't give such a good yield,
but to tinker around
with it and get the yield up so
that it becomes acceptable
in a sequence like that.
But a physical organic chemist
finds such a situation
valuable, because it's a
borderline.
There's a delicate balance
between going this way and
going this way.
And now you can see changing
this effect, changing the
solvent this way, making it more
polar or less polar,
putting a methyl group on,
taking a methyl group off.
You can interpret small effects,
so it allows
sensitive tests of subtle
influences.
For example, isotope effects.
Remember that a deuterium
isotope effect, we said the
maximum is about a factor of 7
usually.
So that's not very big in terms
of
kilocalories per mole.
But even though it's not a very
big effect, even though
it's a small thing, you can
interpret it, because you know
that it must involve breaking a
hydrogen away in the rate
limiting step.
And finally in our discussion of
SN2 and E2 eliminations,
I'm going to give you a valuable
lesson that was
learned, he taught himself, by
Jo-David Fine, who as you see
here was the class of 1972 at
Yale College, and was doing
undergraduate research during
the spring of 1971, so 40
years ago he began this project.
And he continued it through the
summer when he lived on
York Street, and then through
the fall, and the next spring
as a senior, so this was his
research project.
Now what was his research
project?
There was an interesting
question he wanted to ask that
required preparing this
compound.
And the question was this: if
you have a very viscous
solvent, can motion of the
pieces be a rate or product
determining step?
Usually we think of bond
formation or bond breaking
being a rate limiting step.
But obviously for two things to
react with one another,
they have to get together.
So that requires motion.
And if the medium is
sufficiently viscous, and the
reaction that follows when they
get close together is
sufficiently fast, then it could
be that the rate
limiting step would be motion,
not breaking or making bonds.
So that was the question that
Jo-David wanted to find the
answer to, was whether it was
possible that motion would be
the rate limiting step, even
very subtle
short range of motion.
It's easy to imagine that long
range motion
could be rate limiting.
For example, in free radical
chain reactions, you have
radicals floating around.
Once they find one another,
bingo they're gone.
That's the termination reaction
that stops the
machines in the free radical
chain reactions.
So obviously what's rate
limiting is moving them
through the solvent.
But that's long range motion,
how about very subtle motion?
Can it also be rate limiting?
So this is what he was going to
do.
He was going to use UV light to
knock out a molecule of
nitrogen between these two
radicals.
So the two radicals are almost
next to one another, but
there's a nitrogen molecule in
between.
But if those two radicals are
going to react with one
another, they have to get the
nitrogen out of the way.
So how do they get the nitrogen
out of way so they
could combine?
Well in fact, these radicals
studied in
solution don't combine.
Why would those radicals not
combine easily?
Any ideas?
Radicals, usually two SOMOs,
come together, form a bond.
Why not in this case?
Lauren?
STUDENT: The methyl groups would
be too close together.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's a
question of
steric hindrance, there are too
many methyl groups to get
in the way.
So that's not what happens.
So in fact what happens, instead
of that, is that you
rotate that t-butyl radical
together with the nitrogen.
So it's just a rotation, you
don't have to actually move
things by translation, just
rotate them to get that
geometry shown at the right.
And now one radical is close
enough to the deuterium on the
other, that you can get a
deuterium atom transfer, which
is very exothermic, easy, and
fast. So that would generate
then the alkene and the alkane,
by deuterium transfer.
Now there's an alternative
reaction
for these two radicals.
Does anybody see what it is,
besides doing the deuterium
atom transfer?
What other action could you
imagine?
Debby, do you have any idea?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Ok, that particular
process
was called radical pair
disproportionation.
That's another way that radicals
can kill one another
besides coupling.
But the second alternative is to
rotate the other group, the
one with hydrogens, which would
give the geometry down
on the right.
And then you would transfer a
hydrogen atom, and that would
be very exothermic, easy, fast,
and you would get that.
So there's a competition then
between transferring hydrogen
and transferring deuterium.
But what's the product
determining step?
What determines which one you
do?
Well if it's the hydrogen
transfer, then we know that
there'll be a kinetic isotope
effect, and you'll transfer
hydrogen more often than
deuterium.
But if it's the motion, then the
two rotations should be
just about equal.
There's not a very big effect
from
deuterium on the rotation.
So all you have to do to answer
this question of
whether this very subtle short
range motion, just this
rotation, is rate limiting, is
to make this compound,
photolize it to knock out the
nitrogen, and see which
products you get.
Whether the deuterium is in the
alkane product or the
alkene product.
If it's 50/50, that says that
there wasn't a kinetic isotope
effect, hydrogen was not being
transferred when the product
was being determined, the
rotation was limiting.
If there is an isotope effect,
then that means that the bond
breaking, not the motion, was
rate limiting.
So that's easy, that's what it
says here.
So all he had to do then was to
prepare this compound.
And notice how the compound was
pretty carefully devised,
not so you can sell it to your
neighbor and make a big
profit, but to answer this
particular question.
So this is in the same spirit as
the Bartlett and Knox
paper, where the idea was to
make some molecule that was
designed to answer a particular
question.
Now often when you're planning
to make something, you draw a
scheme that where the arrow
doesn't show what something
goes to something else, it shows
it backwards, it's
retrosynthesis, that is, what
could you prepare this
compound from.
Well we haven't talked about the
reactions that would get
from that starting material on
the right to this product, but
by the end of the course,
they'll seem trivial to you.
They're easy reactions that
would do that.
OK, so if you could prepare this
compound, t-butyl
hydrazine, then you'd be home
free
according to what we planned.
So you need t-butyl hydrazine.
Now where are you going to get
t-butyl hydrazine?
So it requires having a t-butyl
group
connected to nitrogen.
Well you could buy hydrazine,
that's cheap, you could buy
t-butyl chloride, that's cheap.
At that time 40 years ago, you
could buy a can of it that
size for about $5 or something
like that.
So all you have to do is do a
substitution reaction where
the nitrogen displaces chloride.
Does that sound like a good
synthetic plan?
Kate, what do you think about
doing, say, an SN2 reaction,
to have the unshared pair on the
nitrogen attack the
carbon, displace chloride?
Seem OK to you, or not so good?
STUDENT: I think so.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
Like a HOMO-LUMO interaction.
PROFESSOR:
Yeah, you could imagine the
HOMOs and LUMOs.
Any problems with it?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: Steric hindrance--
PROFESSOR:
Steric hindrance, right?
When you have all those methyl
groups, it's hard to get at
that carbon, and what would
happen instead?
If you can't do the
substitution?
Elimination.
So you're going to have E2 will
be much
greater than SN2 here.
And in fact, E1 is greater than
SN1 too, so you're going
to get this, not that.
So you're going to have to
figure some other way of
making t-butyl hydrazine.
Well fortunately there was in
the literature this paper in
the Journal of Organic Chemistry
from 1958 about
preparation of these hydra--
that wasn't the title of the
paper, but to make the stuff
in the paper, they needed to
prepare hydrazines.
And they say in this paper, that
"we explored most of the
synthetic methods that have been
used for other alkyl
hydrazines.
Most failed all together, or
gave only negligible yields"
when you tried to do it with
t-butyl.
But there was a seldom used
method that had been
discovered by Zerner, and that
worked well.
And it involved hydrolizing this
CN double bond.
So that reacting with water gave
from this half a ketone,
a ketone that I think some of
you have seen, and on the
right, the t-butyl hydrazine,
the compound you want.
So hydrolysis of the immediate
benzophenone.
So the idea is to break a CN
double bond and put water in
there to put oxygen on the
carbon, the H2 of water on the
nitrogen, and you have the amine
you want, it's connected
to another nitrogen and then to
t-butyl.
And it's very common to change
CX double bonds into CO double
bonds and H2X, and we'll discuss
this ad
nauseam later on.
And notice that this reaction is
catalyzed by acid.
The way it happens is you put a
proton on this nitrogen, and
then that resonance structure
has the cation on the carbon,
and that can add water and get
the oxygen on there.
But suppose you protonate the
wrong nitrogen.
If you protonate that nitrogen
and then shift these electrons
in there, now you have the
t-butyl cation, which is going
to lose a proton, you have
isobutylene, and you're lost.
So it says hot acid caused
elimination of the t-butyl
group, so you have to be carried
out at room
temperature, you don't want to
warm it.
So fine, do it at room
temperature.
So this is what Jo-David set out
to do, the synthesis
starts with this compound,
weirdly enough, and you have
to react it with a Grignard
reagent here, which puts the
t-butyl group on and nitrogen,
and then you're going to break
that bond, put oxygen on there,
H2 on there, and you're
going to have the product you
want.
That's the idea, that's the
synthetic scheme.
So in the first place, it turns
out that t-butyl
Grignard is not the easiest
reagent to make, especially in
the summer when it's humid.
So it was hard for Jo-David to
do this, but finally he got
this stuff to add there, and got
the stuff that needed to
be hydrolized, and then he tried
to do it.
He worked on this from April to
October, through the whole
summer, and never got it to
work.
And finally he got very
frustrated, so he telephoned
Peter A. S. Smith, a professor
at the University of Michigan
who had published that paper in
1958, and asked him what
gave. And this is a page from
Jo-David Fine's notebook from
October 1971: "Private
communication with Doctor P.
A. S. Smith.
Most importantly, he stressed
that his published method will
not give the desired product,
instead the t-butyl group is
lost. They haven't been able to
reproduce Lakritz's'
results, nor to make any more.
Although he feels that
hydrolysis in the desired
manner is possible, if
hydrolysis
is killed very rapidly.
He said to, quote, play around
with it." Which of course,
Jo-David had been doing from
April to October.
So the next comment is the one I
really like in his notebook.
"For the sake of public courtesy
and sophistication, I
will reserve my own comments on
this subject." Now in
preparing for this lecture, I
emailed Jo-David Fine, so
there's a happy ending to this
rather lachrymose story.
He's now a respected Professor
of Dermatology at Vanderbilt,
and is the world expert on
Epidermolysis Bullosa, which
is a skin disease, he's a
dermatologist after all.
And his son graduated from Yale
in 2000.
Here he is, you see, wearing his
Yale crew tie.
He's a very nice guy.
And he said in a reply email,
he's a fellow of the Royal
College of Physicians in London
now, as well as a
Master of Public Health and an
MD.
He said, "That project, and my
conversation with that
pleasant prof at U of Michigan,
did teach me more
about the rigors and foibles of
bench research than
anything that I subsequently
experienced as
a postdoc at NIH.
It therefore prepared me for
many more happily transient
foibles during the 19 years that
I ran a bench immunology
lab at University of Alabama at
Birmingham and University
of North Carolina.
As I found out the hard way,
trying to predict 'good
behavior' with cell lines,
antibodies, and semi-purified
proteins was even more subject
to random whimsy then when I
was trying to work with
relatively straightforward
purified chemicals in a far more
structured laboratory
setting as an undergrad." So he
feels that this was very
good training for him.
But the important lesson was
learned by me the next year at
a Gordon Conference in the
summer, up in New Hampshire,
when I ran into my graduate
school friend Steven Nelson, a
professor at the University of
Wisconsin.
He said that the way to make
t-butyl hydrazine is to react
this with this.
Now it's indeed true that 95% of
it is elimination, but that
product is a gas, so it just
goes away.
And the other 5% is the stuff
you want.
Furthermore, it's very easily
purified, you
can crystallize it.
So in one day, I made 10 grams
of it.
This was after Jo-David had
graduated.
So what's the lesson here?
If you have cheap starting
materials, that the yield you
get is not a big deal.
If you got cheap stuff, and you
can easily do it and
purify the product, that's the
way to make this stuff.
OK, so there's a second happy
ending, that Jo-David Fine
then had a successor the next
year when we
actually had the compound.
He was able to make it, test it,
and find out that if you
have a fluid solvent, there's an
isotope effect.
Hydrogen is transferred more
than deuterium, the atom
transfer is rate limiting.
But in a very viscous solvent at
low temperature, the
kinetic isotope effect
disappeared, it was 50/50
hydrogen to deuterium transfer,
because this
demonstrated that motion had
become rate limiting.
So it is possible for very
subtle motion to be the rate
limiting step in a reaction.
So there were two happy endings
to this, Jo-David
learned a valuable lesson, and I
learned something both from
Jo-David and from Steve Nelson,
and from this result.
So this is stuff that'll be
included on Friday in the
exam, I'm sorry that it's taken
so long to do this.
And I'm going to give a review
this evening, but the
registrar seems to be having
trouble getting to work or
something, I'm not sure.
That's not surprising today.
So we'll have a room in WLH I'm
sure, and I'll email you
where it's going to be.
OK now, the next topic is going
to be backwards what
we've been doing.
So what we've been doing is
substitution and elimination.
And the elimination reaction is
of course this, where the
hydrogen and the leaving group
go away, proton and leaving
group minus typically.
So we have a leaving group.
Now the next topic is going to
be electrophilic, as it's
called, addition to alkenes.
Now notice that this is the
reverse of E1 or E2, with some
of the names changed.
So where we have a proton there,
that's a low LUMO, of
course an electrophile, some
place where electrons could be
easily accommodated.
But we can generalize it, it
doesn't have to be a proton,
it can be any electrophile, just
call it EL.
And the thing that was a leaving
group, we're going to
change the name of, it's a high
HOMO.
We're going to call it a
nucleophile, and now with
those changed names, we're going
to reverse the reaction,
and take the alkene to a
substituted alkane.
Now there are a number of
questions involved with this,
both ones involving mechanism,
and ones involving synthetic
practicality.
One is what can you make?
That's a synthetic question.
What can electrophile and
nucleophile be?
And you'll see that they could
be a wide range of things.
Then there's a mechanistic
question, is this a HOMO-LUMO
kind of reaction, or does it
involve
singly occupied orbitals?
Is it a free radical reaction?
There's the question of timing.
Do you make both bonds at once,
or do you make one bond
and then the other?
And if so, which one?
There's the question of
stereochemistry.
Do the electrophile and
nucleophile come in on
opposite sides of the double
bond, or on the same side?
And that's particularly
relevant, of course, if they
happen to be in the same
molecule, then almost
certainly they have to come in
on the same side.
But if you come in stepwise, one
first, then the other side
can flop around.
So you could attack either side
of the other one, even if
the two things are coming in
from the same side.
You could attack the opposite
face if it was
stepwise and it rotated.
So that's going to be an
interesting question, whether
the product is from syn or anti,
we studied that already
in elimination, whether
elimination was syn or anti.
And then there's the question of
regiochemistry, or as it's
sometimes called orientation,
whether the reaction follows
Markovnikov's rule.
Now Markovnikov's rule happens
when you have an unsymmetrical
case, and you're adding HX.
So you can have X go on the
carbon that's more
substituted.
And a name that's sometimes been
given to this is the
Matthew Rule, from this Bible
quotation, Matthew 25:29: "For
unto everyone that hath shall be
given, and he shall have
abundance." So the carbon that
already has two methyls gets
another X, an H goes to where
the H's were.
Contemporary economics seems
often to work that way, that
the people that have a lot get a
lot, right?
So that's one rule, that's the
Markovnikov rule.
But sometimes, it's
anti-Markovnikov, the product
puts the hydrogen on the carbon
that has more things.
So all these are questions we're
now going to address.
Last year we had a guest lecture
from Professor Siegel
from Zurich who talked with a
more synthetic
perspective to the class.
If you want to read his lecture,
you could listen to
it and see what he wrote on the
board on the web for last
year's website.
But anyhow, from a synthetic
perspective, the idea is you
have an alkene, an unsymmetrical
alkene, and
you're going to react it was
some AB reagent, and put A on
one end and B on the other.
And what can A and B be?
That is, what products can you
make from an alkene?
You can imagine putting two H's
on, an H and an X, an H
and an OH, two X's, X and OH, OH
and OH, or you could
imagine OH and H. Now we already
had H and OH, but this
is different.
It's a different orientation,
like that Markovnikov,
anti-Markovnikov, and the same
here with these.
So in the course of the lecture
he went through and
showed a number of reagents and
filled in this scheme of
what happens, and what kind of
stereochemistry
you have and so on.
So that's the synthetic
motivation for studying these
things, what compounds can you
make from alkenes?
But we're going to take, you
won't be surprised, a little
more physical approach, and look
first at the
thermodynamic stability of some
of the alkenes, and then
at how they react.
Now you wonder where you get
this information about
stability of compounds.
A great place to get it is from
this website, which I can
get on the other computer here.
If you put NIST, which is the
National Institute of Science
and Technology [correction:
National Institute of
Standards and Technology] into
Google, you get this.
And the very first thing you see
is Chemistry WebBook.
So if you click there, you get
the Chemistry WebBook and I
think I've got that here too.
And then you can search in that
WebBook by different
criteria, and the easy one is
formula for our purposes.
And let's suppose we're
interested in butenes.
So we have C4H8, and let's work
in
kilocalories, not in SI units.
So let's search and see what we
can find.
OK, so here's what I just found,
and it's also on here.
So I have 1-butene, 2-butene, in
two flavors, Z
and E, cis and trans.
Then I have 2-methyl-1-propene,
an isomer,
and cyclobutane.
Also methylcyclopropane and
2-butene, generic that is, not
separated as to isomers.
So let's just look at 1-butene
and see what kind of
information is available.
So we see there's all kinds of
data available here.
Gas phase thermochemistry,
condensed phase
thermochemistry, phase changes,
reaction
thermochemistry.
That's particularly interesting,
but let's first
look at gas phase
thermochemistry.
So here we see the heat of
formation in the gas phase is
almost 0, it has about the same
energy as the elements
graphite and hydrogen do.
And if you look at the heat of
combustion it's this.
And what's particularly
valuable, is you can see how
well it's known, what the error
limits are.
These data have been evaluated
by here ALS, which is Afeefy,
Liebman, and Stein.
But it also gives where the
information came from.
So if you click on that, you get
that those things came
from Prosen, Maron and Rossini.
Now this Rossini is not the guy
who wrote
The Barber of Seville.
It's Frederick Rossini, who was
a great thermodynamicist
who measured lots and lots of
these things.
Notice incidentally that also
there's a lot of data from the
Thermodynamic Research Center at
Texas A&M in Texas.
Now Rossini started at the
National Bureau of Standards,
which is what's become NIST when
it got renamed, then he
went to Notre Dame, and then he
went to Rice in Houston.
Now some of you are from
Houston.
Why should somebody who lives in
Houston be interested in
the energies of hydrocarbons?
He measured a zillion
hydrocarbons.
Why?
Cassie?
STUDENT: Oil?
PROFESSOR:
Oil.
This started in 1942.
The American Petroleum Institute
started a big
project to determine
thermodynamic properties of
all the things that could be in
petroleum and refined
petroleum and so on.
So this was done first at the
National Bureau of Standards,
then to Mellon Institute in
Pittsburgh as it was than, and
then he went to Rice.
So there's a method in what
they're doing here.
And I'll be back up.
OK so we've got that.
If we go down a little further,
we could look at
reaction thermochemistry.
So this is the heat evolved when
you do a reaction, so
notice that here is 1-butene
becomes 2-butene,
trans-2-butene, and here are
different people who measured
it, either by equilibrium
constant, or by isothermal
calorimetry, and these are the
values they obtained.
And you can see they're pretty
similar to one another.
That the 2-butene, the
trans-2-butene, is more stable
than 1-butene by about 3
kilocalories per mole.
Now you can go down in this to
other reactions.
These are different reactions.
There's adding HBr to 1-butene.
The one I'm looking for--
here's going to the
cis-2-butene.
Oh that's the first one I had.
So cis and trans.
You see it's a different energy
involved in going to
cis and trans.
But the one I really looking for
is a little further down
here in the middle here, is
adding hydrogen to get butane.
So here for that reaction--
wait, I'm out of sync with
what's over here.
This is changing 1-butene to
cis-2-butene, and here are all
these values for that.
And the next one over here on
the web is the one I just
talking about, 30 kilocalories
for that.
But you can also do it, and I'm
not going to do it over
there for the sake of time, you
can see how much energy is
giving off in adding hydrogen to
cis-2-butene, and how much
to trans-2-butene.
Now these differences in energy
that you get here--
wait, here now--
all give the same product.
Now there's a big advantage to
doing a reaction that's not
very endothermic or exothermic.
It's not like combustion, which
is 600
calories per mole.
To take one thing to another
that involves rather small
amount of energy, like this
adding hydrogen to the alkene,
and to take three different
isomers and convert them to
the same thing.
You see why that's a nice
experiment to do?
Yes?
STUDENT: You can make more?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
STUDENT: You could make more of
it?
PROFESSOR: Well you could make
more, but
not many people want to make
butane.
You get that for free, or from
the petroleum to begin with.
It's for purposes of
measurement that it's important.
Because if you're measuring a
small amount of energy and
make a 2% error, it's not very
much.
If you're measuring 600 calories
and make a 2% error,
that's 12 kilocalories.
But here, you see these errors
are a part in 200, a part in
300, a part in 300.
So now you know all these
compounds relative to the same
compound, to very high
precision, which means you
know the relative to one
another.
So that's the way to really get
the data properly.
So here's a table from a
textbook, I think it's the
Jones textbook which gives these
things, but you've seen
now where it really comes from,
from this NIST webbook.
Here are data I collected from
the NIST
webbook for the hexenes.
And you'll notice that a whole
bunch of them were done by
Professor Wyberg in the 1980's
and 1990's, the guy who talked
to you last year.
And this is a problem to do
after the exam, so it could be
due next Wednesday, say
something like that, a week
from today.
But to try and look at these
numbers here, the relative
stability of the hexenes, and
see whether it's consistent
with what you find for the
butenes in terms of the
relative energies.
That is, are there regularities
of the energy
between cis and trans double
bond?
Of the difference between a
double bond at the end of the
chain, and a double bond in the
middle of the chain.
Can we make generality that way?
So that's a fun project to look
at.
But the first thing to do is to
get to the exam on Friday,
so I'll talk to you this evening
about that.
That's it.